The Spectator magazine combines incisive
political analysis with books and arts
reviews of unrivaled Authority try a
month in print and online for free and
for a limited time only get a free
wireless phone charger go to WWE taco UK
forward slash charger to start today
hello and welcome to audio reads on the
podcast this week we have Katy boss on
the long-term impact of the Dominic
Cummings affair dr. John Lee on the
problem with the way we're counting
covert deaths and Lionel Shriver on how
life isn't worth living without a little
risk first Katy boss on Dominic Cummings
when the cabinet met by conference call
on Monday three ministers spoken in
support of Dominic Cummings Jacob Riis
MOG Sarala bravoman
and Priti Patel their sentiments are not
universally shared several of us started
feeling ill when Jacob opened his mouth
says one attendee silence from the
parliamentary party is damning they had
but many critics of Cummings and I think
that having dug and so deeply the Prime
Minister has to keep his man to need to
fight this much for an aide as bad
enough but to fight in loose would be
devastating
this explains energy behind the pursuit
of Cummings in the past few days the
disclosure that Boris Johnson senior a
traveled 260 miles from London during
lockdown isn't just an easy issue on
which to criticize the government
he's also provided the Prime Minister's
critics with their biggest chance yet at
destabilizing Johnson's operation it
became clear pretty quickly that this
was not about the fate of one advisor
but about the authority of the PM and
the viability of his government anyone
unconvinced need only look at the
lengths taken to protect Cummings he was
given a personal press conference in the
dining street rose garden once used for
the coalition announcement the Prime
Minister offered his full backing at two
fairly press conferences a slew of
cabinet members were sent out to offer
their support and a review of lockdown
child care penalties was even mooted by
the health secretary if I were anyone
else he would no longer be in place says
the minister but Cummings is not as
important as an average cabinet member
he's far higher up when Sajid Javid as
Chancellor came to blows with Cummings
he asked Johnson to choose between them
he found out the hard way where the PM's
loyalties lie Tory MPs have long been
comfortable of all this and the idea of
an all-powerful number Tanner issuing
orders
now that Cummings is in the firing line
there's fire an opportunity to try and
change things when they work together an
education Michael Gove described
Cummings as his demon the animal
manifestation of a person's inner self
and Philip Pullman's His Dark Materials
who fed off his instincts and did things
that he as a minister would not dare
Cummings work ethic his effectiveness
and his lack of interest and their
opinions of critics tend to get results
he helped go past the academies act in
66 days he helped Johnson when the
brexit referendum and then helped him
secure Tory majority of 80 against all
the odds his style is to work with a
tight team taking quick decisions to
apply these methods in a system
supposedly run by cabinet government was
always going to cause tension the weekly
cabinet meeting has become more
decorative with many of those present
sensing they're going through the
motions the cabinet is already split
into the inner Cabot Cove Matt Hancock
Dominick Rob and Richie sunic are on the
prime minister's morning coronavirus
call where key decisions are taken and
information shared several of those
cabinet ministers not present nicknamed
the outer cabinet have grown resentful
of being left in the dark cabinet
ministers see in the latest drama an
opportunity to change the Power Balance
to their advantage he will struggle to
command the same respect as before or
even to give orders I'll use one others
agree we need to stop treating him as
some high profit rather than an adviser
they had the locks and hooks are
pressing for his change in tone on
social distancing altering the emphasis
so that everything is allowed except for
specific things like certain industries
remaining closed on the grounds that
would read the most clarity in the
current climate while ministers may be
working at hide together
upper hand is the backbenchers who will
prove harder to control even before this
episode number tampered little time into
wooing MPs or nurturing party morale
it's harder to do in lockdown
it took jobs in several weeks to hold a
zoom call of his party troops aides and
whips have already been facing up to the
reality that a majority of 80 doesn't
allow you to just do what you like
a recent u-turn on the NHS migrant
surcharge showed that the speed at which
Tory MPs have gone public to criticize
Cummings should give further food for
thought
the rebellion runs deeper than the usual
suspects as well as old foes including
Damian Collins and Steve Baker a raft of
new MPs in the red wall have aired
concerns if you don't have your new
intake onside what are you even doing
complains one bemused MP are usually
loyal MP says they have been looking for
reasons to support number 10 fitness but
are struggling to find them I don't have
any axe to grind it's hard to defend in
their court of opinion this is an
unwinnable case they add some have at
least found a line to argue supportive
MPs have been telling sceptical
colleagues that this will end up as
Stallman a Westminster tea cup
look they say at the fate of David
Cameron's spin-doctor Andy Coulson in
the end nobody cared about Coulson they
say no it didn't exactly end well for
the Cummings drama is a story as much
about the Prime Minister as it is the
aid that Johnson had become so reliant
on any individual has triggered alarm
his decision to spend so much political
capital keeping his aid in place has led
to questions over his judgment put it
this way it's crystallized people's
sense we are not handling this crisis
right it's as a moderate conservative MP
a lot of people are openly saying can
Boris Johnson do this they had at the
start of a five-year Parliament there
was time for wounds to him and time to
reform Whitehall in a way that removes
the need for a Svengali this is oddly
enough coming stated mission as it was
blog in January to hire more people and
make himself largely redundant by
Christmas but for now there was no one
like him no one the Prime Minister needs
more the battle to depose him will
continue for some time yet that was Katy
boss and now dr. John Lee on what he
thinks is a problem with a way
accounting covert deaths as a
pathologist I am used to people thinking
that my job mainly involves dealing with
death but nothing could be further from
the truth that is why I and many of my
colleagues are so dismayed by changes
introduced during the corona virus
epidemic which means that pathology has
not been able to play the role that it
should have in helping to understand
this new disease the word pathology
tends to conjure up images of body bags
more trees and murder investigations
hoh-hoh people say your patients can't
answer back they imagine days spent
trenching across fields to reach murder
scenes Silent Witness style and nights
sifting through arcane evidence to catch
the perpetrators and a rare type of
pathologist the forensic pathologist
does indeed do that most pathologists so
spend the majority of their careers
looking after the living after all
pathology is the study of disease and
the whole point of knowing about
diseases is to inform our approaches to
preventing and treating them there are
four main types of pathologists
microbiologists specialized in the study
of infectious diseases a subtype is the
biologist in particular demand at the
moment chemical pathologists are expert
in the liquid parts of the blood they
analyze the endless samples that pour
into path maps day and night looking for
changes in chemicals and hormones that
indicate disease and hematologists are
experts in diseases of the blood cells
the red cells are the white cells that
can cause problems such as anemia or
leukemia and then there is my own
specialty of histopathology or cellular
pathology we are experts in analyzing
changes in the fabric of our bodies that
result from disease many diseases affect
our tissues in ways that can be seen
down the microscope allowing them to be
accurately diagnosed and monitored
particularly tumors and inflammations
every time a biopsy or surgical sample
is taken it comes to the histopathology
now to be examined histopathology is
often regarded as a gold standard for
diagnosis of diseases that change tissue
structure a clinical examination or
x-ray may suggest that the tumor or
fibrosis of the lung se is present but
you need to examine the tissue sample
microscopically to be sure that it's
really
what type it is and how advanced tissue
can also be examined genetically to look
for the presence of infectious agents or
cellular receptors that may determine
how deadly it is the other thing that
some histopathology just do is autopsies
hence the confusion with forensic
pathology but in this case the autopsies
are not typically looking for evidence
of foul play
they are usually requested by a coroner
to ascertain the cause of death
relatives even doctors are often
surprised by the need for this in the
world of modern medicine
surely all the examinations tests and
imaging carried out in life means that
the treating doctors know what was wrong
with the patient when they died
but no it turns out that autopsies often
reveal the unexpected tests and images
can be misleading and treating doctors
may have fixed ideas about what the
matter is based on first impressions or
incomplete evidence autopsy also OPS's
literally means seeing for oneself and
the person doing that should be
clear-eyed an independent specialist
medical practitioner with no emotional
or professional vested interest in what
happened to the patient autopsy studies
typically show major discrepancies
between actual findings and clinical
diagnosis in a quarter to a third of
cases and in about a sixth of cases
knowing about these hidden pathologies
in life could have made differences to
treatment that might have prevented
death in the UK in recent decades about
1 in 6 deaths have had an autopsy
examination and deceased persons last
gift to the living the results
contribute to maintaining and improving
care verifying and upholding the
standards of public health statistics
preventing diagnostic drips and
basically keeping medicine honest
autopsies also allow a sampling of
tissues from more organs than is usually
possible in life facilitating molecular
and genetic studies and know where our
autopsy studies more important than in
the study of new diseases and new
treatments the best example of this in
recent years was acquired immune
deficiency syndrome or AIDS when aids
first appeared in the early 1980s no one
knew what it was how it affected victims
how to treat it or what affects its
potential treatments
had knowledge about all of these aspects
were substantially acquired by study of
tissue samples taking during life and by
autopsy examinations the study of
samples acquired after death there was
much uncertainty worried at the time
about how the disease was spread and
possible contagion to healthcare workers
and to the general population but work
continued that the results were of
immense help in understanding the
disease and developing treatments
looking at the current crisis the
response so far has been very different
we are still struggling to understand
coronavirus I can think of no time in my
medical career when it has been more
important to have accurate diagnosis of
the disease and understanding of
precisely why patients have died of it
yet early on in the epidemic rules
surrounding death certification were
changed in ways that make the statistics
unreliable guidance was issued which
tends to reduce rather than increase
referrals for autopsy normally two
doctors are needed to certify death one
of whom has been treating the patient or
who knows them and has seen them
recently that has changed for carried 19
only the certification can be made by a
single doctor and there's no requirement
for them to examined or even met the
patient a video link consultation in the
four weeks prior to death is now felt to
be sufficient for death to be attributed
to Kovac 19 but destined care homes the
situation is even more extraordinary
care providers most of whom are not
medically trained may make a statement
to the effect that a patient has died
okay with 19 in the words of the Office
for National Statistics this may or may
not correspond to a medical diagnosis or
test result or be reflected in the death
certification from the 29th of March the
numbers of Kovac deaths have included
all cases where Kovac 19 was simply
mentioned on the death certificate
irrespective of positive testing and
whether or not it may have been
incidental to or directly responsible
for death from April the 29th the
numbers include the caring cases simply
considered likely to be coded 19 so at a
time when accurate death statistics are
more important than ever the rules have
been changed in ways that make them less
reliable than ever in what proportion of
Kovac 19 mentions was the disease
actually present and in how many cases
if actually present was Kovac 19
responsible for death despite what you
may have understood from the daily
briefings the shocking truth is that we
just don't know how many of the cases
during the epidemic are due to coma at
19 and how many are due to our societal
responses of Healthcare reorganization
lockdown and say for distancing again we
don't know despite claims that they're
all due to carry 19 there's strong
evidence that many perhaps even a
majority are the result of our responses
rather over disease itself it might have
been possible to check these proportions
by examining the deceased but at the
time and autopsies could have played a
major role in helping us understand this
disease advice was given which made such
examinations less likely than might have
otherwise been the case the Chief
Coroner issued guidance on the 26th of
March which seemed designed to keep
covert 19 cases out of the colonial
system the guy that said the aim of the
system should be that every death from
coma 19 which does not in law require
referral to the coroner should be dealt
with via the deaths interrogation
process and even guidance produced by
the Royal College of pathologists in
February stated in general if a death is
believed to be due to confirm decay with
19 infection there is unlikely to be any
need for a post-mortem examination to be
conducted and the medical certificate of
the cause of death should be issued we
need proper information to inform our
responses to the virus both clinical and
societal instead we have no idea how
many of the deaths attributed to Kovac
19 really were due to the disease and we
have no idea how many of the excess
deaths were really due to Kovac 19 or do
the effects of lockdown official should
be releasing as a matter of urgency
detailed information on the surging
deaths both apparent coded and on code
with particularly in Cairns
how many are dying of Cobie requirement
hospitals data presumably exists on this
too but is not released the first rule
in a pandemic took me to ensure
transparency of information without it
errors could go undiscovered and lives
can be lost we will never be able to
find out for sure now what this disease
was like or what it did in the early
stages of the crisis one of the
unappreciated
in this epidemic so far is the huge lost
opportunity to understand Kovac 19
better
we'd like to beat ourselves up for
having worse clover death toll in the UK
in Europe but we will never now know
because we decided not to count properly
in a country that's always prided itself
on the quality of its facts and figures
the missing komak 19 data is a national
scandal that was dr. john lee and now
Lionel Shriver who asks is living
without risk really living at all taking
my life in my hands as we all do when
getting out of bed I walked along the
Thames last week on the northern
footpath east of Blackfriars Bridge a
young man ran atop the adjacent wall and
jumped across a gap in the brickwork the
gap was 6 feet long the wall is high had
he missed he'd have met all manner of
hazards on either side he gained nothing
overt from that leap only an ephemeral
sense of satisfaction it risked broken
bones or a fractured skull as he turned
heel in preparation for repeating the
feat I was both aghast and impressed we
could call that young men foolhardy
yet I wager that an ephemeral sense of
satisfaction is precious to someone in
his 20s and could in time transfer to
making leaps of a metaphorical sort
later in a career when I was young I
took an enormous leap of faith by
committing to becoming a novelist a risk
of which I was under aware at the time
which to most clued up observers was
foolhardy in the extreme the age group
most inclined to elevate safety to the
highest of virtues is the elderly old
people are more physically fragile the
shank of their lives is behind them
including their own feats of derring-do
while there are many delightful
exceptions seniors as a cohort are most
likely to value tranquility and
protection from harm overt new exports
and adventures societies also have
stages
of life by locking down during the
corona virus pandemic you knew I'd get
to that the whole Western world has
clung to safety above all else
we've willingly traded prosperity
functionality joy good company and the
productive futures of upcoming
generations for short-term security
that's a security narrowly defined as
well individual medical security as
opposed to the broader more long-term
security of a sound economy in a
thriving community hysterical safety ISM
is the mark of a society that has passed
its peak the West has subsided to a
geriatric phase of high anxiety and low
expectations with safety as a prime
directive Sir Ernest Shackleton would
never come anywhere near the South Pole
because he might have got cold
David Livingstone would have found
Victoria Falls only in order to wash his
hands in it Sir Francis Drake could
never have set sail because rubberized
non-slip decking had yet to be invented
Winston Churchill would certainly not
have sanctioned Dunkirk because someone
might have got hurt given how popular
this domestic pastime has proved during
lockdown serrano fines would surely have
spurned Mount Everest for the staircase
in his house after taking a course in
proper stair climbing technique from his
local council donning knee pads in a
crash helmet and stopping for frequent
water breaks to remain hydrated perhaps
in future will adulate a whole different
set of national heroes will give Olympic
medals to gymnasts who realize that
flipping around uneven parallel bars is
terribly dangerous and so if prudently
set out their athletic careers in a
chair the winner of the Tour de France
will be the cyclist who never rides
faster than 8 miles an hour and
remembers to wear sunscreen will award
the Victoria Cross to the safest member
of the Armed Forces in
presence of the enemy who comes under
bombardment and hides in the boot of his
Jeep or who safely joins the other side
if it seems to be winning look I wear
seat belts during the pandemic I've not
been bursting into covet wards and
begging positive patients to lick my
face cycling down steep hills these days
I tend to ride the brake a tad but I
recognize that giving the thrill of
speed a miss in order to handle the
unexpected is a sure sign that I'm
getting old accepted when Kovan first
hit available data was patchy but before
the UK's lockdown smaller studies
already pointed towards what the US
Centers for Disease Control hardly a
hotbed of libertarian nut jobs announced
last week the infection fatality rate of
kovat 19 is nowhere near 3.4 percent as
first feared but around 0.2 6% seasonal
flus IFR is 0.1% 0.2% in an especially
bad year thus kovat 19 is barely more
lethal than a bad flu true flu can be
wretched and even fatal but we live with
that risk every winter now that this you
think comforting information is in most
Britons are still cowering in place when
guests on the news say there's no such
thing as perfect safety or we always
live in a world of competing risks these
self-evident bromides fall on deaf ears
you can't prove a negative it's
impossible to demonstrate that schools
or workplaces are not unsafe if early
humans were too frightened to leave the
cave to hunt for food none of us would
be here what's wrong with you people
what's made this country so formidable
for a thousand years being incredibly
careful
meanwhile isolating school children
within chalk circles may have a
negligible epidemiological effect but a
profound psychological one
we're inculcating chronic fearfulness in
our kids who will skip from the
helplessness of infancy to the neurotic
hyper caution of old age with no moon
landings in between we've prioritized
the preservation of life in a literal
short-term sense possibly losing more
lives than we've saved once the
collateral damage totals are in while
giving no priority to everything that
makes life worth living like the
experience of bravery that young men
leaving a gap in the wall relished last
week course we've thrown the future of a
generation under a bus safety is fine as
far as it goes but it's not the driver
of a vibrant culture safety is about
status if all you care about is safety
you never leave the house lock down our
no lock down obsession with safety is
the very opposite of ambition
no wonder China is flexing its muscles
the Western response to covert 19 is an
ominous sign of civilizational
senescence that was Lionel Shriver
thanks for listening to this episode of
audio reads and do join us again next
week and remember if there's anyone in
particular you'd like to hear from or
any feedback you'd like to give to us on
any of our podcasts not just this one do
you just email podcast at spectator code
or ek we do read all of your emails
thanks so much for listening and join us
again next week
[Music]
The Spectator magazine combines incisive
political analysis with books and arts
reviews of unrivaled Authority try a
month in print and online for free and
for a limited time only get a free
wireless phone charger go to WP tatertot
UK forward slash charger to start today